there goes to the body the commanders
notices it's not moving it's lifeless do
you get someone to bring it slowly in
put the body on it and just cast it out
[Music]
The Early Childhood was a one of
or violence and being subjected to
beatings and be dad was just sitting in
the house getting buried all the time he
was on the Yale you know
and
it was a bit of a it was a bit of a
boxer back in his day so for me I wanted
to impression but I wanted to be
acknowledged and loved by him and I
joined the boxing club
it was more of a family than the one at
home
and a member on an arm excited telling
me that I was having a fight between
first fight it was in Waterloo
and he was sitting in the front room
smoking a cigarette
but it's kind of lager by the shadow
this year
I was about 12 to 18 years old said I'm
fighting dad
and he just he didn't even look at me
he's just shared if you don't lock him
out in the first round I don't want to
knock you out
that's all he said to me
what did boxing mean for you at this
time boxing to me you know I won I had
about 16 fights and I won a massive
majority of them
you know I had dreams I wanted to to
join the Army I wanted to to Boxford
England
and I kind of like
found myself
moving away from me
because your stars are far then you know
friends outside of the gym
the training and the fort is saying and
became a little bit can't be bothered
I'm getting up in the morning doing that
one go on the gym you know I felt like I
was missing out all the time if I don't
go if we go to the gym we're going to
miss out on this
I'm getting off of joints and drinks and
I don't worry but I feel an issue to fit
in you picked us you picked up a
substance now you're
you know you need to go and fund The
Habit that you've developed
and that's what happened for me you know
when I started small Cash videos
you know doing what you do is kids to
phone these
there's no there's no money there's no
jobs
how old were you the first time you went
to jail and what was it for
I was um
I think it was about 17. it was an
attempted robbery
I was hooked by this time on heroin
and I just went out and blocked someone
what I tried to
get arrested by the police and you
remind me in hm why or why Henley in
Wigan
and I remember let me show one one
one one morning and the weather was boom
and I was sad it was Desert
of course I've had an office
I can't cope I can't carry on like this
no more
I want to follow me Mom I haven't spoke
to my mum for about a year see there's
no way I am
I don't think me my case I don't think
anyone cares I'm not getting no lessons
and not get no visits you know I feel
really lonely
that was my mom's number
she answers after a few
a few things and I said Mom it's me
Billy and as soon as she hear my voice I
had
I could hear the love and name
wow
it just it just hit me like that's on a
bridge like solid in the chest and I had
this
this overwhelming feeling of like
like emotion and the eyes were well
enough
but these two screws were standing next
to me and I thought I cannot blink here
I couldn't even speak to me mum because
I knew my voice should tremble and the
series it just falls on my face and she
knew it was like her mother's instinct
she just said Sean I know you're in
okay
because they said me teeth I was okay I
just went back to shell shot in that
shell and I shoved
a
once that's always short I'll also last
set of application officer they came to
see me she welcomed me the ocean look
I'm on drugs I want to get off them I
don't want to get out I don't want to
live the life I'm living what can you do
for me he said we can name
you can put you up in a rehabilitation
upon release
Bristol
you know I thought like geographically
Liverpool was the problem and I never
understood that the problem lies within
it always has done
that's five years clean now I had about
three months on the meatballs so when he
was a God I put him on a pedestal five
years have you stayed clean of heroin
and crack cocaine left for five years
and he was just show me you know
this new way of life he was a little
full of Adventure he'd been abroad I
thought I haven't left Liverpool
he's telling me he's going to Thailand
he'd be in the year before
but I like to come
show me this idea
tell me what a great place it was to be
the food
you know the culture everything about it
was a incredible
and I fell in love with the photos of it
here we go three months backpacking
that was the plan anyway
you know and I'm like a whale Clash card
carrying pleasure chica you know I just
wanna you know experience fun and joy in
in every other way but taking drugs or I
want to relive like lost the aims and I
want them so awaken and I love boxing as
a kid and you know I love Ty will you
say boxing I love watching it I love
watching the sports
you know I remember me saying to me
don't get in the ring with these eyes
like they'll break it up
it's all gone on the ring
and I swear I got my lips broken within
the first two rounds
election and I was resenting the kid who
did it and I said I'll come back and six
weeks later I got back another Pizza
you know I Fell In Love With It Boxing
did that become your kind of predominant
thing that you ended up doing in
Thailand like was that your main focus
yeah boxing was definitely the main
focus in Thailand um
kept me there he gave me papish I was
disciplined
you know I was maintaining the recovery
and what I did do was yeah because I was
you know because I was I could speak
English obviously
I mean we'd walk around with the boxing
I'd speak to the
other source and say you know can we
support these boxes because they're
putting on the show and they'd give me a
little bit of a money at the end of the
night and I began it became a regular
thing every single night I was fighting
three four times a night
but I always thought even though they
were like it was show fights today my to
me it was a real fight you know I was
moving away from right
the meetings and recovery and spending
more time
you know with these tires and in the
ring and meeting
girls and I met this girl and I fell in
love with that she couldn't speak her
words of English the relationship was
based on a dictionary you know when I
found out that she had another fella
although the partner
I was just so broken and show it and
show the looted
and they owe me feelings were all over
the place and I'm getting anything
was not the answer it didn't solve
the problem it didn't take away the pain
and I remember sitting in a bar on my
own
staring at this thing
unless you can have a double whiskey
party it's in front of me
you know you gotta remember I'm three
years abstinence of this this time
in there staring at it and it's like I'm
fighting with myself
you know it's kicked in
I just picked it up and I drank it and
that was you picked up the phone spoke
to her another Foreigner that I knew he
was
he was actively taking drugs and
drinking
someone to meet me
he met up and said what's he need I said
cocaine
came back about five minutes later and
gave us these
little pink pills
but
Wi on them
whatever you want to do these one
tablets didn't one ecstasy or
no no you smoked them put them on the
foil started to show us how to do it
build a little tube put in a mold
put a little flame under this pill and
it just changed it turned into oil
because that's as a bubble and smoke
starts to come up
it's passed to me
it's just a nail bill
I got this
feeling
that's just
troll there it was just
exhilarating
you know I wanted more
were you aware of the the potential
consequences of being caught with drugs
in Thailand because it's quite severe
penalties
you know what to be honest I remember
it didn't really at all madam when I was
buying these drugs and taking them
you know I felt it was Untouchable I was
invincible because the police had pulled
you up regularly on these motorbikes and
you wouldn't be wearing helmets and
they'd be taking backhanders off yeah
and you know they were cut off those you
know as as a police force over there it
is
and that's what I thought had happened
you know it always get away with it
us to be fair I started I developed that
habit with the Yabba right that's it as
soon as I pay her abusion I'm in
negative Edition I need a fun day fight
wasn't a novel was an Aaron enough money
shiman offered me a way out as a pack of
pills she'll learn to the shortest in
the clubs you know you can use you can
you can you can pay yours what you need
to and and life can be a little bit
better for you so that's what I did and
a big mistake
when they played in my room the police
they were looking around like is this
like a Rambo movie what's going
on here there was no windows in this
apartment it was just a dingy little
apartment to shut the door sat with me
back against it thinking oh yeah
Papa
it's always getting banged bang wrong
that's just a bang bang bang
open the door police
and I went no I don't believe you froze
your idea I'm stalling the new which
leads away the police know what I mean
an ID card come under the door I didn't
even look I just seen a face
open the door
Dave Ross then add me on the floor Face
Down Eyes behind me back a little
Clapper clip around the back of the head
and that was you I was arrested
I'm going down
how was that first night in prison and
and how did you feel
I remember going into the shell and it
was just
shocker
with Siamese there was about 80
inmates in the show
I was like a tennis shoes
there was no space whatsoever
and I looked it around the early eyes
looking up at me
I had to put that mask on again I was
satisfied
Swagger
and I went and I got older to sleep in
the corner next to this guy who passed
away they've got strobe lights on
24 hours a day
you go out in the morning
you know the Sean's hitting you
at six seven in the morning when you get
opened up you get out until about five
in the evening it's still late you put
in your shell the lights are on in your
shell you've got a hard concrete floor
there's no mattresses you know I'm
sleeping next to a trolley you know
people living in a note
there's no privacy
you know you know when I'm eating food
and it's causing problems in your
stomach and you know for diarrhea and
I'm all the time
I'm still suffering with throw rolls
with these drugs you know I'm using on
the slight ends you can't really use
anything anyway you have to go so early
like the toilets put a blanket over you
I mean the toilets outside and the
compound will be people shell on the
buses they'll have makeshift tents and
they'd be selling their bodies for
cigarettes and
a mango
how were your fellow inmates uh treating
you and and I suppose how are the guards
treating you being a foreigner
well I was a
I was very volatile and reactive
and I couldn't
communicate with them and that was your
struggle and finally explained to them
how I felt and you know telling someone
I was feeling shy and I felt lonely and
hate and you know not being able to
to convey that to them to to the size
was really difficult and if they speak
to me and I could sense they were
speaking to me with a bit of venom
which is like a pack of socks you don't
want they all jump on you and I had that
a few times I remember coming out the
first morning
and getting
involved in a fight with these three
photos
these two Australians and an Iranian
wanted me over there with a chair one
punched me in the head with these metal
rings
go down
I'm not getting up
the whistle blows guys come running they
break it up I've got blood all over me
this kid's got blood all over him I get
taken
to the
the hospital
I'm in this chair
these guys are looking at me and they're
laughing at me and I'm already feeling
lousy about what's happened and I
reacted and I threw a punch at this kid
this side
is already having a bath
knock me out and I remember him waking
up
to this I thought it was a girl
Tavern
cotton ball over these cuts
I thought wow she's beautiful
who is she
oh it's a you know
and we're there show me some compassion
and understanding and empathy
you know it was
it was nice to feel
that that kind of intimacy if you can
understand me
I was transferred to clangbrang Bangkok
prison
after about a year of being in Chiang
Mai in in Chiang Mai there was over 4
000 inmates and that was a small prison
when I went to Bangkok you know I had
twenty thousand I made so it was a it
was it was a different kind of a daily
and I was warned that you know Bangkok
was a lot more dangerous than
you know a Chiang Mai Chiang Mai was
more forgiven I remember
by this Library
one afternoon and this young Thai as ran
past me
behind them and he had a knife in his
hand
the guy with a knife
getting closer
then suddenly
a tight next image come running out with
you know it's just a metal chair I'll
just stop this kid and distraction whack
them
right across the face eased the floor
this guy's on him and he's stabbing him
and it's a knife it's not a homemade
knife it's a proper knife and he's
stabbing them and the death shots
they're going in the neck they're going
in the lungs to just it's just cold
calculating not enough friends he's just
stabbing him in the back and the legs
and and the screams you were absolutely
inhumane
it was him it was coming from the very
you know depths of his bowel it was
horrible
um
and I just stood there
like Sans fixed I couldn't intervene it
was like he was happening in slow motion
I looked around the crowd started
together it was about 50 people and they
were screaming calm and calm and calm
and I didn't know what that meant at the
time
but I do know it means kill him
and
um
these two commanders just casually
walked over
after the the car that dispersed the guy
with the knife it got off
he's on the floor and the pool of blood
I'm still standing there there's a
couple of other foreigners with me we're
all like looking are you sure they're in
disbelief
they go to the body the commanders
it's not moving it's lifeless
do you get someone to bring it slowly in
put the body on it and just cast it out
the Muay Thai boxing are you able to
talk about your experiences with that
I'd had enough you know I didn't want to
fight the prison I did the money
um
be put in these shells
on my own or
letter
I wasn't going to fight back all the
other times looked at me you know
with suspicion and I got a pair to Mets
put them on as I had to punching away at
the bag
and the Machine that he had a few skills
and Taj loves the best you know what I
mean so he said look we've got a strong
Crown which is the Thai new year I think
it's in April and they they have these
big shows
you know I got friendly with the the
boxing coach he wants to put me in with
one of his best boxers called Pawn
I remember getting in the ring there
that afternoon
it's a cheers and Applause and you know
people put bats on me and
you know it was an incredible feeling
and I thought that guy and I beat him
and it was him
the respect received from the rest
of the prison and you know the boxers
Museum
was heartwarming
the feelings he gave me
you know it was better than any drug
I've ever took and I'd always
like regretted
no
having a career in boxing and
I don't know
it kind of
humbled me it gave me that discipline
and that routine
it allowed me to
to face me face
how long in total were you in prison in
Thailand and what year were You released
I'd say three years
I went in 2005 I got released from
Thailand England
September
Brunswick London
and how did you feel upon your release I
fell to him it was a different culture
shock I was founded I struggled to adapt
it to him
to
the UK way of living
I was comparing the price of everything
the people you know I was very sharp
shavings it was yesterday no share you
know I was beating there was beating
down when I was in Thailand I was you
know you had to really be below the
guard so everything even like the the
screws in one's Worth or quite like you
know I went to they put me in prison in
Wadsworth and I I took away the Masters
and slept on the floor
but then I wrote about it
and I thought to me that was the most
therapeutic
thing I could do was write
because you know
I couldn't escape the waves on the paper
how did you manage to get back onto a
straight path from that point
so yeah well to me it was a like a detox
initially you know
get off what he was on I knew there was
a way out because I've been there before
I just had to kind of
to play you know apply it to me life
goes through the detox gets through them
get special recovery it was okay and he
said
you start
you know building a bridge to normal
living get a job
you know get yourself a house get a cab
all the stuff done
we're meant to do in life and care
you know I think I got a true career but
it's a book that became like that
shallow within six months which was
quite bizarre
it then it became a movie and like I was
overwhelmed with a
the producers and people knocking at my
door and ringing me up and actors
getting you know
um casted for this role and inscription
directors and it was like you know I
didn't know how to deal with it all
you know and then I get it with cancer
stage three
you know in the midst of it all
I mean dad has just passed away the year
before
and I was put on chemo
um
I went from 16 Stone to nine Stone
within 12 weeks lost all my year
I got a big pay out of this from this
movie
where pay me even though I couldn't go
in
I got credit cards I had loads of money
I was clean for five years
I had
of course I was going to die anyway I'm
going to go out with a bang
um
finish the course of chemo there was
nothing left of me or lost me I also
lost my car
I was a the oncologist sat there
thinking okay I like means a match
this is it
you know anyways Mr Moore you're okay
you know glass of Shea you're gonna
you're gonna be fine
you've cleared the cancer and I went
what you mean I was like you having a
laugh
I said hello all kinds of Molly house
and I've got even
okay so the least you need to pay the
bills and how are you now brilliant
they share the quote and have kids I've
never had children and
you know now I've got a two you know
yeah so you say
yeah he's a medical shower
I mean forgive me for being emotional
because yeah apparently
it's always
it's always something
that I've wanted in my life is to Nature
a little me
and allow
sort of like into all these choices and
and
you know do what he'd like to do instead
of being beaten and batted I could never
imagine
like hating them the way I was here you
know what I mean
it's give me like
that opportunities to
change someone else
um
bring them up the right way
[Music]
I had to strip down to next to nothing
grease up put a towel over the cut
section of bar off the window so I
wouldn't scratch my back and leave it
myself out whilst and rinse that up just
another little inch probably strangling
everybody had always hated since
childhood but just enough for me to get
out